so what would you think is like the
craziest most dangerous Contraption
you've come up with in your opinion oh I
think it would probably be one that I I
did and I was like no I won't muck
around with that before and it's with
electricity
um and I did that uh we're halfway
through doing it I realized how
dangerous it actually was that it's like
well because I realized I didn't take
you that long
I didn't even [__] around yeah yeah
so and that's yeah I realized I'm not
smart enough to do that in a snake yeah
I mean like like a retro boom that dude
yeah yeah you should muck around with
stuff that if you make one mistake you
die instantly that's that's mine yeah it
seems like he knows what he's doing but
it's still dangerous you get a lot of
views though for that for that one video
yeah yeah it'd be great to be the
biggest video on you it's got to be in
4k at least as well so easy 4K
um but you you guys on your so that you
do the channel called boy boy and this
kind of started after your channel right
um
it was just terribly unpopular for years
it shows how much I did my research
um but I think the first time I'd seen
anything of your channel and I thought
it was fake at first because I thought
there's no way this could be real they
you both went and I'm not mistaken you
both went to North Korea just to get a
haircut yeah yeah and I'm sure you've
I'm sure this has been like the Press
thing you always have to talk about like
yeah tell us about North Korea but like
I mean why the [__] did you do that oh
that was our first ever video as well
yeah yeah it's like a debut on YouTube I
think we were we wanted to go to North
Korea for tourism and um
just casually just just casually because
it's so it's so weird like you just hear
so many stories about it and how it's
this kind of mystical place with these
crazy rules or like we wanted to know is
this true like right yeah and then ended
up just making a video out of it like
that was our first ever thing on YouTube
how are you to film anything that were
they not like super strict about to be
fair I think there's a lot of
misconceptions about the place like it
was the filming was really chill over
there just because I mean you're on a
guided tour essentially they want you
they want you feeling like they want
everything they show you they're like
show the world this place is a paradise
yeah yeah yeah so if if one of our
viewers wanted to go to North Korea for
tourism which I'm sure like a lot of you
guys watching are what's like the
process of like getting the Visa and
like getting over to North Korea it's
honestly easier though exactly like
we're on the North Korean tourism board
it's honestly easier than any other
country we've gone to just because
it's so easy to do because their tool
companies are set up to do all of it and
I think we paid it was kind of pricey
for what we were poor students at the
time but we paid like a thousand bucks
for five days but you just send off your
details to this Chinese company
there were some dodgy bits like um oh
when you got that call in the morning
yeah yeah we well there was a couple of
things so the lead up to this scary call
in the morning was um they said you can
take photos of anything but the one
thing we don't want you to do is take
photos of the military
um so after a day being now I was like
well I'm gonna take photos of the
military so I just started taking photos
of the military and then one time they
saw me doing that
um so they started they asked if they
could go through my camera and then they
were going through my camera looking for
the photos of the military to delete
that but it was really funny because you
know how um if you record a video it has
a thumbnail yeah which the thumbnail was
there and they thought that was the
photo so they were just like why is this
guy taking photos of the ground like
right I didn't look through any of my
videos but they deleted some photos of
the military
um and then so that kind of put me on
their radar so then I was a bit stressed
like oh I've pissed them off you did the
best emotional manipulation on them that
was insane they stopped going through
your camera because you started crying
yeah I started crying
can you have the camera
because they started deleting photos of
the travel and I took this photo of this
like really like this boy was sitting
down at the river and he was like
fishing I took a photo and I thought it
was like and they deleted it and then I
started getting tears in my eyes that
they like they stopped they stopped
deleting the phone I had these guys be
so brutal but like they just see a grown
man crying
that's where the compassion kicks in
yeah what are monsters
they're worried about the Press though
yeah yeah it's weird that we worry about
the Press when they're just arresting
other people yeah yeah oh my God it's
just weird that they'd care about that
yeah we're like all the tourists kind of
stay in the the one like specific
tourist Hotel yeah right and like you
never really know what's going on
everyone's kind of assuming that it's
all bugged and they're listening to you
and stuff and then one time we were out
we're like privately talking we're like
okay if it is bugged let's just tonight
when we go back we'll just talk to each
other in gibberish all night
um just in our room and hopefully
there's a there's a North Korean person
behind the scenes like flicking through
the translator
we did not give up for like hours
how closely were you guys monitored were
you guys allowed to leave the hotel room
at all kind of like quarantining we
could just walk around the hotel we paid
a bit extra to do like a private tour
for the last days and then that's like
more or less they said it was a walking
tour of the city and we imagined oh you
just get to walk but it was like they
took us to a street and then the two
guides walked down the street to the end
and then back up to our starting point
yeah and it was like yeah it's a very
restrictive you don't get to see very
much they're showing you what they want
you to see right the good parts but was
it good the good parts or was it just
kind of like that it was actually fine I
mean like yeah a lot of the good parts
seem fairly nice
um and that's the best it gets I guess
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but the one
weird thing was I think they've got this
um Vision that they're they're actually
like this best in the world kind of
YouTube yeah and so some of the photos
that they had issues with like Alex
taking a photo of that kid they were
just like oh he's he's Barefoot you
can't have that you know that looks he
looks poor and it's just like dude
people don't wear shoes Alex never wears
shoes Australia one time and also the
kid was like swimming in the river with
no rubbish and we just came from China
where everything's like covered in
rubbish and we're like no this this
actually looks pretty chill yeah yeah I
feel like calm down to get into nothing
yeah yeah
how was how's the food there I'm curious
uh I mean it I don't think it's a fair
judgment because we obviously paid money
in the yeah I think they would obviously
it was delicious it was just like did
you get to go to like a local restaurant
or something or whatever they took you
to yeah
right right because I don't think there
are local restaurants
I I actually I don't think I've ever
told this story on the podcast before
but um so it's this is like one of the
weirdest experience I've ever had right
so I was um this was when I was living
in Thailand and uh I was uh out with
Sydney at the time
um we were walking around and we were
just like trying to find a restaurant
wrong we're just in like the middle of
Bangkok uh and we see this one massive
restaurant and we rest uh we recognize
that it's a Korean restaurant so we're
like great I'm I'm craving Korean Let's
uh let's try going in
um and then we we head in and then
something's like something's like off
because we go in and it's a Saturday
night it's a massive [__] restaurant
and it's completely empty right right
and then we uh the servers come up
um and we soon realized that we're in
Thailand so we expect them to at least
speak Thai or their second language a
lot of people speak English uh they did
not speak any Thai or any English at all
uh and so and for some reason all of the
girls uh they're all girls there all of
the girls who were serving us had like
this look like
um like they had a gun pointed at them
or something like that and it was and it
was super super weird so we got we're
going to this restaurant and uh they
serve us
um and they were and there's like two I
items on the menu or something and one
and I was like what the [__] is going on
here right uh so the only person who
spoke Thai there was the manager who
kind of didn't really know what was
going on uh she she was like uh I asked
her well what's uh what's uh would you
recommend on the menu and she was like I
don't [__] ask the girls and so I try
like communicating with these girls oh
what do you what do you want on uh what
do you want on the menu and uh I was
like uh is it okay if I leave
um to like the manager and uh she
translates to that to the girls and she
um and the girls like no please please
please don't leave uh I'll I'll get you
this this I recommend this uh it's okay
I'll I'll get you this right now and uh
so we uh we get this like I think it's
like a chicken soup or something
uh and the entire time the girls are
like I don't know the girls just look
scared something was off for this
restaurant and in the end uh they ended
up double charging my cards and I try
explaining hey I think you've double
charged my cards and they're like no we
haven't and I explain to the manager
you've double charged my card and she's
like I can't do anything about this what
the [__] Eric I actually feeling wrong I
recommend you just leave right now and
so and so we leave and I'm like that's a
weird [__] experience and so we
Google it
and we find out that it is a
state-funded North Korean restaurant and
we we had just like walked into a North
Korean state-funded restaurant and I was
like I didn't know this existed you know
crazy yeah yeah they're like like
basically like they're kind of held
hostage but yeah I heard about this
because I think there's a video probably
like [__] half as interesting doing
it or something about how yeah the
Korean North Korean government funds
like restaurants of North Korean food to
kind of get people to appreciate the
culture more yeah but I'm surprised it's
bad service because like we had the
opposite in North Korea where it was
like so like obsessed on making
everything perfect that it was just like
almost freaky in the other direction
right right this is too much like chill
out or maybe it's because you guys were
in the mainland right so yeah they had
like a standard to fill up whereas like
you know them in Thailand they're just
like I was gonna [__] walk in here
they know yeah also I bet they spoke
fluent Thai on English they were just
trying to scam you yeah
oh my God that's terrifying was there
anything about North Korea that
surprised you guys that you weren't
expecting
I think well some I mean the
relationship with the leader was pretty
confronting what you expect yeah because
we went there to try and kind of like
you know look at it from a pretty like
neutral point of view and try to like
maybe dispel some of the western things
right um stories about North Korea but
yeah the stuff with the leader where
like every single person has the
leader's face and they're viewed as a
God yeah
um and there were some Hilarious Moments
where we went to the Museum of
friendship where they had I just want to
cry like it was the place where there
was all the gifts that Kim Jong-un had
received from leaders around the world
because everyone loves it because
everyone loves it yeah they're best
mates and one of them was like a gift
from the Sam the CEO of Samsung from
Korea and she shows us this cabinet and
she was like this is the all the gifts
from the CEO of Samsung and inside the
cabinet was just Apple computers from
like the 90s it's like the latest
Samsung technology and we were just like
trying not to laugh you're like they
just how do they don't know like they
haven't another one there it's just so
hard because you see how Earnest these
people are who are telling you this
stuff I'm like I cannot because they
generally believe it right yeah yeah
they have this portrait there that he
was gifted I forgot from who and it's
like this is our dear leader riding a
tiger in a suit of armor smoking a
cigarette and I was just like and he's
on top of a mountain smokers he's just
showing us we're just like trying not to
laugh so hard like oh my God this is
just just get so they're just like
proudly showing everything off and a lot
of them are [__] weird
they don't know any better all right
something about Mausoleum or something
oh yeah because like the the dad and the
Grandad so yeah
they're embalmed over there and um
two shorts North Korea version that is
um it was so bizarre because we go there
to like you'd even pay your respects and
um and you uh we get out like I don't
know how far away it was like kilometer
away from the actual Mausoleum you don't
actually go when you go into this like
underground bit and you're on
travelators like the and you stand on
there and they're going slower than
walking pace and it's just the North
Korean national anthem blaring and
you're literally standing on that
travelator for like an hour it was like
it was probably like half an hour and
they made us standing 16 so four by four
people and we had to just stand still as
we like floated down this elevator with
like pictures of uh just North Korean
Landscapes and then we got to the end
and there was this you get to these
different rooms where like one of them
had um like brushes on the floor that
like clean your feet and then you go to
another room that blows all like the
dust off you can be nice and clean
before you see the guys
when you finally get there it's like
it's so sad you've got there's all there
with a bunch of other North Koreans and
like everyone's crying it's like oh no
these guys are dead
um
you've got guards like armed guards
around around them and like the guards
are crying like the guy's like wiping
away his tears and they're like you're
there every day
this job never gets easier
I was really lucky because I had a bit
of a cold so I was like sneezing in
teary the whole time it's like this
great I'm fitting in perfectly I'm
legitimately crying yeah so we got him
to North Korea
you know because obviously I imagine
there's something in your passport
that's like I went to North Korea yeah
if you've had any questions in America
yeah we are like why do you go we had to
get interviewed um because normally
Australians can go like on a Nestor visa
to America but we can't we have to go
and get interviewed by the American
guards who asked the weirdest [__]
questions
which was just so weird and they're so
strangely so intimate about it so just
because you went to North Korea yeah and
it's like what do you think I'm a spy
there's the worst spy in the world
what kind of questions are they asking
like oh just why did you go there did
you enjoy it did you enjoy it I was like
what if I say yes about his wife so I
was like it was weird yeah you're trying
to like do you want me to say it was bad
there was just the most pointless
questions yeah like well you're not
getting anything out of it it's like
it's pointless but they're also just
like angry at you like it was like am I
wasting your time
I just loved it that we're getting
interviewed by Americans about North
Korea I look behind the guy interviewing
me and there was a massive portrait of
Donald Trump looking like Kim Jong-un I
was like it's exactly the same it's the
same place actually they made us like
they took all our stuff and like um we
were like they took they took our shoes
and we just walked through the embassy
Barefoot and we're like wow yeah there's
some pretty hectic it's not true that
would not be allowed yeah yeah no no
shoes
Jesus so do you get a question every
time you go to America or uh no it was
just the once when we got but once the
Visa expires we'll have to do that again